Deadpool didn't just shake up the status
quo for action adventure starring guys
and capes it went the extra mile and set
a lot of cinematic precedents some of
them quite subtly if you can believe it
this is how Deadpool changed movies and
you barely noticed
Deadpool's marketing is basically a
movies worth of entertainment in and of
itself seriously for Mother's Day gags
two billboards that shouldn't exist the
folks behind Deadpool pulled out all the
stops to make sure the hype would be at
its absolute peak by the time the
superhero hit the big screen what made
it so special isn't just its excessive
over-the-top humor but also its not so
subtle Metta slant befitting the
character Deadpool's marketing made sure
to tap in to fourth wall breaking
territory showcasing a degree of self
awareness that elated the meme
generation you're probably thinking my
boyfriend said this was a superhero
movie without surprise this is actually
lucky you a love story this movie knew
its target demographics so well that it
transcended its own status resulting in
Deadpool's pre-release antics being
shared as entertainment rather than
advertising this led to an unprecedented
degree of organic word-of-mouth which
likely played a huge role in Deadpool's
debut as one of the biggest r-rated
openings of all time somewhat if Justice
League has a listers like the flash
Aquaman and Wonder Woman no one cares
about them or that movie be Lister's are
the new hot property after all Deadpool
was only as good as his red-suited Merc
and his ensemble of backup dancers which
included beloved comic book characters
like hang on let us check her notes
weasel and negasonic teenage warhead
negasonic teenage what that's the
coolest thing ever
oh yeah neither of these were fan
favorites and while Colossus definitely
has a following it'd be a serious
stretch to call him an a-lister really
the cast of this movie from top to
bottom was as b-list or below as a guy
and that's probably why it worked so
well virtually none of these characters
had to worry about living up to
overwhelming audience expectations
meaning there was minimal pressure and
maximum freedom to adapt them however
would best suit the film and that's
exactly what Deadpool did writing them
smartly and entertaining
enough to fit within the film's universe
while simultaneously maintaining their
core comic-book identities for those
reasons the movie nailed building its
own team of budget Avengers effectively
proving to Hollywood that you don't need
an Iron Man or a Wonder Woman to produce
a moneymaker loaded with franchise
starting characters it's a big house
it's funny that I only ever see two of
you it's almost like the studio couldn't
afford another x-man if there's one
movie that shines as a prime example of
what fans can accomplish when they band
together to create buzz on the internet
it's Deadpool if not for the leaked test
footage we might very well have never
gotten a Deadpool solo movie at all but
Fox felt compelled to dish out 58
million dollars which isn't even all
that much in superhero movie money as a
result of a lot of geeks on the internet
screaming about how much they wanted
some goofball in a red jumpsuit to shoot
people and say bad words at a time we
live in we all sort of said Venus
someone should leak it someone should
leak it so subtly the idea was planted
I'm 70% sure it wasn't me though we've
yet to see another brave test footage
leaker come out of the woodwork to make
their hypothetical dream movie a studio
budgeted reality it doesn't change the
fact that the Deadpool situation and the
response by thoughts set a new precedent
in the filmmaking world when the
Internet speaks can make real change in
the old days Hollywood was a gated
Kingdom where the true power brokers all
wore suits and traded business cards
moving forward we now know another party
has a voice at the decision-making table
the fans it's just a matter of making
enough noise a lot of films fall into
the trap of being overly sincere or in
more recent years too self-aware movies
like Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
showed us what can happen when a movie
takes itself far too seriously on the
other end of the spectrum if every other
minute in the film is littered with self
referential dialogue then there's no
room whatsoever for real emotional
investment by the audience Deadpool the
first and best of its medic ein showed
that it's possible to be extremely
self-aware but also the gently emotional
at the same time Deadpool type most of
its fourth-wall breaking antics to the
main characters superhero alter ego so
that whenever weighed in Vanessa were
sharing an intimate real beat no cynical
self-deprecating humor would crowd
and ruin the moment your life is
officially way more than mine it was a
smart balancing move that ensured
audiences would care about Wade and
Vanessa's happiness and well-being while
also being able to laugh at all of
Deadpool's zany shenanigans
prior to Deadpool few thought that a
movie loaded with CGI gunfights throw
downs and explosions could ever operate
as a functional comedy guardians of the
galaxy was as close as any superhero
film to come to achieving that and even
that movie veered more into
action-adventure territory
Deadpool went for the guffaws right from
its opening title sequence all the way
till the very end of its credits for the
crowds who liked raunchy Seth Rogen
comedies and Seth MacFarlane's comedic
fare this movie fit the bill and felt
more like a Marvel flavored big-budget
parody than an actual superhero movie
Deadpool's effects on the industry are
readily apparent it might have come out
later that same year but given the
extensive reshoots Suicide Squad went
through one convince your guests that
the movie's sudden influx of meta humor
might have been the result of Deadpool
success and just look at you Sam another
keenly self-aware superhero movie that
unlike its DC EU contemporaries is
actually well fun who's to say what kind
of tone it would have aimed for without
Deadpool to prove that a superhero movie
doesn't have to be such a brooding mopey
affair do you like what you see no you
look like an avocado had sex with an
older more disgusting avocado yeah check
out one of her newest videos right here
Plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]